[Music]
we've talked about the olympics it's a
big thing to chat about these days and
uh they've been impressive so far very
impressive in a lot of ways but one of
our writers isn't happy with the
olympics yeah it's he's irked about
something he wants to talk about it
right now please welcome mr dion cole
thanks conan i've been watching the
olympics and i am glad to see so many
african-americans participating in so
many different events but we haven't
cracked the trampoline
black people we've come a long way but
until we conquer the trampoline we are
not truly free as a race
so i've decided to become the jackie
robinson of the trampoline
so are you all ready to make history
with me tonight
wow
this is amazing let's do this
i can't believe i wasn't told this is
incredible we're about to make history
with america's first black trampoline
artist very exciting go for it dion
let's see what you got
whoa
okay not bad
and he's oh that was pretty good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's right the idea that he died
[Laughter]
he almost didn't make it through that
wall i know it's a lot weaker at
rehearsal
i'm surprised that killed him he barely
made it through and then he fell about
two inches
onto a padded mat
let's just go with the idea that he's
dead right oh there he is there's his
board there's his corpse that's proof
that he's gone and i know he's moving a
little bit
maybe we were wrong